Britain's Queen Elizabeth has reached an
agreement with her grandson Prince Harry
and his wife Megan that will allow them
to give up their roles as working
members of the royal family they will
cease using the title Royal Highness and
will no longer receive taxpayer money
last month they said they wanted to lead
a more independent life the Queen had
insisted that framework of Harry and
Megan's future be drawn up quickly after
a week of talks the monarch released a
statement saying the family had agreed
on a constructive and supportive way
forward her grandson and his wife will
no longer be working Royals this means
from now on the couple did not formally
represent the Queen and are required to
step back from royal duties for Harry
that includes his official military
appointments this is an abdication in a
sense from the royal family by Harry and
he and his wife are now free to a
certain extent to go and follow the
dreams that they have to pursue very
good works it would seem in the widest
possible sense we're not going to see
them on boil engagements in this country
beyond this spring the Queen says she
recognises the challenges Harry and
Megan have faced in two years of intense
scrutiny the pair plan to spend much of
their time in North America the attenti
rest in their story is likely to remain
extremely high they're unlikely to step
out of the spotlight entirely